welcome back guys uh as you know here on
the channel we've been doing a lot of
plot leaks lately and this is for doctor
strange and multiverse of bandits so
what i did is i took all the trailers
and clips and i organized them for you
and i compared them to the leaks that
we've seen so far
stick around the the audio obviously is
going to be a little different just
because i cut it up and not necessarily
um
obviously as the trailer intended them
to but bear with me it definitely does
put the whole movie in perspective let's
get started
the nightmare begins
we'll walk through it
look out
become a hero
prove it
it's too dangerous
why we tampered with the stability of
space time
later you'd show up
i made mistakes
and people were hurt i'm not here to
talk about westview
then what are you here for
i need your help
guess what
what do you know about the multiverse
this had his theories
but i become the enemy
it doesn't seem fair
he believed it was dangerous
he was right i
hope you understand
who or what
you break the rules
[Music]
i'm sorry steve
will not go unpunished
[Music]
we should tell him the truth
greatest threat
[Music]
what do you know about the multiverse
between universes
and we don't know
your desecration of reality
i dream the same dream
is you
things just got out of hand
meant for any
if this
did what i had to do
this path exacts a heavy toll
and obviously we wouldn't see anything
from the finale in the trailers uh so
there is at least probably 30 minutes
left in the movie from the point at
which uh defender strange's dead body
comes back to life uh so let me know in
the comments what you guys think i i
worked hard on this when this one was at
least a couple days
worth uh i had to put together all the
pieces from all the trailers and clips
and i organized them for you i would
really appreciate a subscription if you
don't mind i am doing this every day so
i'll see you guys tomorrow thank you so
much have a